have you ever felt really uncomfortable with a person or a situation
but you weren't able to articulate exactly why?
it's probably because there was a conflict with your personal core values
for example one of my personal values is independence
so when I've experienced micromanaging
it's not just something that annoys me or that I don't like
it's actually a violation of my values
and while some people might have told you that that's normal
it's just part of life or you have to suck it up and deal with it
I'm here to tell you that that's not right
you deserve to be able to live your values fully in every area of your life